did you know you could do this
this tip is given to us by an in-game
note which says your opportunities for a
plunging attack will be rare indeed and
while that is true the hitbox on this is
really janky you can definitely pull off
some spectacular kills
give it a try and i wonder are there any
other enemies that are open to plunging
attacks what other secrets haven't we
found yet
this game
is absolutely brimming with hidden
content and i feel like this secrets
video is going to be the first of many
on eldon rings so subscribe for that but
in this video we're going to be talking
about all the noteworthy secrets that
from software themselves have written
down for us
most of these you can buy from the
merchants found throughout the game and
while some of these notes aren't worth
the paper that they're printed on today
we're going to talk about the ones that
are and also
how the most hidden of these notes lead
you to the dark secrets of the merchants
themselves
now for this next secret i want to try
and help you defeat an enemy that i know
a lot of you have been having trouble
with
the land squirts the need to be nerfed
honestly it's [ __ ] but until then
you can defeat them with poison easily
it's counter-intuitive but poisoning
these things overloads them with toxin
and they can't expel it fast enough so
they tragically explode in their own
poison cloud
this in turn poisons the land squirts
around them who explode and poison the
ones around them and so on and so on
it's kind of sad watching them fall
victim to their own poison in this way
but also strangely satisfying
the same strategy can be used against
the giant land squirts found in
northeastern leonia and the scarlet rot
variants as well found in kailid which
can also be overloaded with scarlet rot
pick your poison or don't and just knock
them over with a couple of r2s instead
land squirts are softest where they
touch the ground
another counter-intuitive strategy can
be used against the royal revenants who
actually are extremely difficult and a
lot of people are having trouble with
they never give you a chance to heal
which is the hardest part
that said if you do get a chance to heal
your damage
they might just take damage instead
any aoe heal can be used to absolutely
destroy them in this way and if you use
more powerful heals that's even more
true this same logic applies to their
followers as well who are all cursed
just like them thus your heels will harm
rather than men
curiously you can even sort of poison
them with healing over time spells which
is a great touch if you want to make
them suffer and i know a lot of you do
i've seen the forum posts
another contender for the most hated
enemy are the stormville warhawks
particularly the ones that peg fire
barrels at you
use gravity magic however and you can
just devastate them the same goes for
any flying foe they will all be brought
low by spells like gravity well or ashes
of war like gravitas another enemy you
can bring low are the stone digger
trolls whose heads bear old wounds with
one well-aimed ranged attack preferably
while they're doing that raw they'll be
left reeling which gives you ample time
to charge the martus and bring them to
their knees this next note is a little
less useful but interesting
slay the demi human mobs leader first
and the rest will lose hope and panic
i mean you should probably always be
killing the little guys first if you can
so i'm not sure how helpful this one is
but it is cool to see their tribal
dependence on a leader from a gameplay
point of view
speaking of things you can't see though
have you fought an invisible black knife
assassin yet
they're tough i only beat my first one
by relying on spirit summons to point
out where they are
luckily though there's a better way of
beating these guys the merchant in the
hermit merchant's shack sells a
century's torch which is bestowed with a
special incantation that allows the
bearer to see assassins cloaked in veils
it was this invisibility that allowed
the black knives to steal the rune of
death and slay godwin the golden ages
ago
thus century tortures were given to old
tree centuries such that a knight of
black knives would never come again
another type of revealing light is
commonly seen in hero graveyards this
light stems from roses staff and it can
be used to make shadow enemies
vulnerable while you're going through
these dungeons as well remember
sometimes these enemies need to be
defeated in order for you to progress
speaking of rosus this is a character
that you see represented all throughout
the lands between
he is the usher of death and when his
statues are activated they shine a light
that points towards a dungeon
sometimes what he's pointing to is
really obvious and sometimes the light
is pointing you towards dungeons that
are very hidden indeed specifically
though this light always points towards
catacomb type dungeons after all the
dead easily lose their way and have
always been in sore need of a guiding
hand
i think they're looking for a way back
to the roots of the earth tree which
seem to always appear in these catacomb
dungeons for number 10
there is a hidden cave in the town of
celia look beyond the graveyard at the
precipice
so
yeah they're using the term town pretty
loosely here you have to go quite far
north to find the illusory wall behind
the graveyard this is the cellular
hideaway it's a glintstone cavern that
you'll need to find at one point if
you're on sorceress ellen's quest line
and her questline leads you through a
locked door that you can find within as
well but if you're not on that quest
line you can also pick up a crystal
torrent spell which recently got buffed
a crystal spear
and the crystalline ashes which are an
excellent summon against anything that
doesn't use blunt damage i'd recommend
it
next for number 11 we're going to start
talking about the merchants this nomadic
tribe they're absolutely intriguing and
there's so much more to them than you'd
expect you're first introduced to them
at the start of the game of course with
carly who can be used to kick off
blythe's questline after hearing a
howling in the mist wood speak to kali
and he'll say this the howl of a wolf
in the mist wood
i suppose he must still be skulking
about
i know
why not meet him for yourself perform
the emote here in the forest and i'll
let you see where this quest line leads
kalei also sells a note that tells you
the location of sorceress selen who you
can talk to to kick off her questline
which we just mentioned continues in the
hidden cave in celia
so all of these notes are written by the
merchants they probably have a lot of
collective intelligence as a nomadic
tribe and they sell this to adventurers
but one of these notes tells you not to
go somewhere and it's a note about the
frenzied flame village which is
inhabited by the sick and located south
of the grand lift of dectus
a lot of folks would have missed this
location since it sort of requires you
to double back from the grand lift get
past the tower inflicting you with
madness hide from it just like you hid
from the brain of menses when it
afflicted you with frenzy in bloodborne
atop this tower of frenzy is the howl of
shaburi spell and at the precipice of
the cliff beyond it is the frenzied
flame village
here you can get the shabriri's woe
talisman the frenzied cookbook and you
can also have an encounter with vike who
drops a frenzy spear and also a grape
for hayeta who is an npc whose quest
line goes down the path that i'm about
to describe
perhaps the most curious thing in this
village though is a corpse of someone
who has died of frenzy in the corner
hidden in some bushes there's a note on
his body that hides a clue that will
lead you further down the path of frenzy
like the others this note is of course
written by a merchant and this one tells
us who their lord is beneath lane del at
the very bottom lies our lord lord of
the frenzied the three fingers who holds
us in thrall
note that when you fight a merchant a
lot of them fight with frenzy this note
prompted me to explore further beyond
the sewers it led me to a new boss fight
and then when i knew that this couldn't
possibly be the end of the path it
prompted me to go even further to
activate the passageway behind the boss
fight and find the odd thousand corpses
of frenzied folk that remain here they
look a lot like merchants they probably
are merchants they have the exact same
little hand scratcher violin bow that a
lot of them wield i'll let you venture
further down here and discover this
place for yourself
at the bottom you'll find a very curious
door one that most characters won't be
able to open straight away
so this is the 14th secret which i will
provide and i'm gonna make it a riddle
for you so here it is only the wretched
will be able to get past this door
and if you do get past this door you
will unlock a new ending although fair
warning you should probably talk to
melana at the grace after you come down
here to figure out if this is an ending
you'd actually want and also while
you're down here turn to the right after
you drop down and go through the
illusory wall for a runak and the
entrance to the deep root depths which
is an area that just has the most hidden
entrances to it but this is actually a
pretty convenient one while you're down
here further back though we find another
note and it has the final clue to all of
this in case you regret getting past
this door and the path that it puts you
down
so to get this note you have to trick a
frenzied enemy into destroying one of
these makeshift huts and the note within
it reads the empyrion michaela crafted a
needle to resist the influence of the
outer gods those who have inherited the
flame of frenzy yet wished not to become
its lord would do well to seek
mckellar's needle in order to get
mckellar's needle you'll need to follow
millicent's quest line all the way to
the end it starts with gary here in
caled and it ends all the way at the
hallig tree with melania once you have
this needle you can embed it in your
flesh but you can only do so here at
faram azula and here the flame of frenzy
will no longer have any power over you
and it will no longer influence your
ending
i
really want to talk more about this but
it would end up being like a 30 minute
lore video so subscribe for that if
you're interested i love that this
secrets video ended here though it's
just a small taste of the story that's
to come as elden ring's law is just
maddeningly addictive before i go though
please consider listening to audible who
graciously sponsored this video now it's
no secret that if you love the world
building of elden ring then you'll
probably love the world of the witcher
as well my favorite way to dive into
this world isn't actually through the
games though it's through the audiobook
this is the last wish a collection of
short stories that went on to inspire
the witcher games have a listen the
stranger was not old but his hair was
almost entirely white
beneath his coat he wore a worn leather
jerking laced up at the neck and
shoulders
as he took off his coat those around him
noticed that he carried a sword
not something unusual in itself
nearly every man in verchima carried a
weapon
but no one carried a sword strapped to
his back as if it were a bow or a quiver
you can listen to this full audio book
or any other completely free during your
trial period so head over to audible.com
slash varity video or text vaatividia to
500 500 and consider signing up this
audiobook is read by peter kenny and he
does an excellent job with character
accents and inflections which i think is
really important in an audio book
another reason i think people will love
this lesson is that it's a collection of
short stories which is just a perfect
format for audiobooks because you can
finish an entire story while you listen
on the bus or while you're doing some
housework things like that so again head
over to audible.com varity video or text
device video to 500 500 to start your
free trial thanks to audible for
sponsoring this video and thank you for
watching
[Music]